what's your favorite Resident Evil game  do you like how the series was  reinvented with resident evil for the  action of 5 the multiple storylines of  six if you said yes to any of those I've  got good news Resident Evil 4 5 and 6  are coming to ps4 and xbox one March  2016 will mark 20 years of Resident Evil  games and Capcom is celebrating with  these releases are a six releases March  29th with all DLC included re5 is  scheduled for this summer and re for is  slated for this fall each one will cost  you twenty bucks Capcom hasn't announced  a physical collection or a digital  bundle at this time so you will have to  grab each one as it becomes available  it's the 20th anniversary of Resident  Evil so don't be surprised if these  current gen ports are only one part of  Capcom's plans for the year we'll  certainly have all the announcements up  on gamespot I'm Tony Wilson you can  follow me on twitter at chaingun Pope  and honestly I'll take any excuse to  play Resident Evil 4 again